each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so let's get started we're very
glad to have a chain wha here visiting
with us it's going to a graduating PhD
student at Stanford University working
with John we chose group on wireless
security his research interests they are
to address the practical security
problems in complicated computer systems
and Sid really interested in real-world
vulnerability and exploit before joining
Stanford he got his semester degree from
University of Hong Kong and a bachelor
degree from Ching hua university
changhua okay thank you thank you for
introducing me yeah yeah yeah I think
okay okay good morning at my limit java
and they always will talk about 80 to
tell you are I security and I see this
work or down with Professor John
Michelle Pfeiffer university as you
might know security have been a serious
concern in wireless networks so people
are people are watching about 11 program
Caribbean and secure wireless local ad
network investors or try to answer this
question my father will be divided in as
follows first hour overview the wireless
local area network security then I
already did I will describe the details
of a total failure and I standard then
I'll agree to own life this standard we
will use Palestine verification to alive
the components we found some
vulnerabilities in a fellow handshake
will provide the solutions the
vulnerabilities and the solutions are
actually very simple but if it
availability and it can launch a very
easy attack so there are standard comedy
adopted we also
from their insecurities on the
improvements too late or too late and I
our talk about the details later finally
we conduct our model approve of the
security very very example to Shula
enter to the level of charter network
generally they'll be as important to
connect you to the lab methylethyl a
menage there will be some wireless
devices magnetopause PDA connecting to
the exit point and the program it seems
that while this video is open to the
public anybody with an moderate
equipment can listen to the traffic an
interview with the traffic even this if
people come may bad antenna by himself
from some very cheap parts like the
empathy can and some parts you combine
everywhere then you can imagine our age
of the radisson video so a real concern
I will do that secure wireless local
network in order to answer this question
first let's clarify let us work on
wireless network first is a very
intuitively is a pass password
eavesdropping I think in strategy means
everybody can eavesdrop there traffic in
the network that's very evasive most
valleys network interface card of corn
excuse load also message injection and
active eavesdropping it very easy if
there are sometimes not hello publix to
generate any packet format and Ernie
package content with the common wireless
card and also that since the mic
protocol is one to be called cooperative
so the attacker can interfere with the
traffic in a very timely way on the
other hand the math education and
interception is a little bit hard are
you still possible and Atmospheric are
in the field peppered reception process
in the receiver side are using a
diversion and panel or using a stronger
power of course mark reading and manisha
ihe is very easy
is the access that access point that
some software to install the as
importantly a regular network card and
the mac address is acceptable but also
some other sophisticated attacks on
wireless network next session hijacking
may in the middle on till our service
attack so in order to defend against all
of those words people are trying to find
some security solution for wireless
network are intimately able to vary 11
the user rather equipment protocol to
achieve this goal they have some
authentication protocols like open
certain authentication and share of key
authentication some vendors will also
use some mac address filtering to do
authorization and there some
confidentiality and integrity protocol
which is a stream cipher also for with
Salafi however visual since 2000 listen
fund company nearly secure so people are
trying to improve race and solve the
problems Wi-Fi allows proposed this WPA
protocol in double play they use 802
para la ex for authentication another
use chi Chi Chi for the continuity and
integrity I plan on to talk about the
details of the base protocols of the
further on the launch we use an extra
hardware from the web so rescue some
problems also availability is a big
program a very straightforward if you
have service at happy surfaces German
and this is inevitable this is expensive
and this is terrible so within
conservatives in steps elementary
application rather that's impossible
attacks from the network and a player
but that's depend on the protocols so
our circles among the link layer I
thought you need there were so many you
have service attacks on the infertility
management friends at nuclear so we have
learned the money's worth on the while
networks and people try very hard to
achieve a secure wireless network now
fun service solutions have
vulnerabilities in bedlam so the latest
intro to belong I standard are trying to
enumerate all of these vulnerabilities
802 very well I or the red fight on jun
20 25 2004 it provides the convention TM
integrity through encryption decryption
in an ink layer if you include include
web and cheek IP for backward
compatibility it introduced a new
algorithm called 33 MP content / CBC Mac
protocol for as a long-term solution for
those long term solution will need hard
work cover your upgrade so we own
terrorized that detailed encryption
decryption algorithm I we believe with
the fresh pl2 rebellion RCMP is secure
so since 6am she is used are AES cipher
an area and that many studies on aes
already our photos around a mutual
authentication protocol and the key
management protocol actually 802 regular
I is quite secure in its original
version of there are still some sample
programs understandable solutions are
very easy so here i will describe the
equilibrium I in Jeter's altitude where
I adults are eyes and a which is whether
security material Association for the
security the island as Emily
establishment procedures contains Molly
stage and many message exchanges our
deposit in later so our security our
efforts without this can provide
satisfactory authentication Annika
management whether they say that whether
there could be problematic in treasure
and security networks and we are from
the whiplash attack on the server
handshake also I would
is that is a big problem here so here is
a company the conversation of 802 11 I
enables repair your other eye last three
entities involved firstly the subsequent
let the secretary could be of any
wireless device like a laptop or a cell
phone or something like that or
otherwise the altima cater there are
syndicated first to be implemented in
the access point they also have set the
server identities authentication server
recertification server could be
implemented inside the single device
with the S indicator or it could be
implemented in a separate back-end
server it's implemented in a separate
server we assume that connection between
them is secure so at the very beginning
the same people I want to talk to the
health encoder we will run an alpha
trooper urm association to set up a food
a connection between that then other
which food commercial set up very the
authenticator will act as veterinary
unless a pretend an authenticator will
run on visual indication protocol to
meet when they authenticate both side
which user authentication protocol will
as soon leave if POS after the mutual
authentication protocol the seller has
shared some key with the traffic on
which is MSP then the server will move
with ms key to the authenticator I'm the
ultimate a Decepticon will derive a
power P then we have a power key from
this master session key so this party
could also be deep reconfig all the cash
PMP before then with this PMP they will
run for a handshake to derive a fresh
session key which will call PGP for
felony possession then we will run a
group to handshake to derive the new
group p for for multicast applications
and so on then based on a groupie and
I life p they were wrong security
professionals okay so I'll go to unlock
the protocol actually we find some very
simple one a bit excited for a it's a
clot under the proposed solution for
that we use silenced in verification to
organize any every component of the
protocol investor power use a fellow
handshake as a seal vample the lightest
through the verification is a very
powerful methodology is its rivalry
using software verification on security
protocol unless it is so the comparative
studies elephants and dynamic choosing
techniques which have no requirement for
including in implementations we can
analyze any specification with document
or the challenges is you need to
understand the government very
completely since you need to coat them
by yourself the along a challenge for
less than verification is vested
stability in fluid is frozen program we
need to reduce the first base such men
without all the many tools available
path for general metal checking and for
the automatic model generation model
checking we will use a method met each
other now the leadership that use
materials for every protocol
participants an intruder to define a
non-deterministic state transition graph
then every every every node in this
graph will represent some state a
material exhaustively enumerate or Gras
floats if there is some security
property violated in the graph the metal
will verify this node and this the past
from the initial 32 this mode will not
contact and pack there is a figure to
show you how to do these things so we
have the informal protocol teeth group
description this could be a threat to
respond or and so on then we will have a
very cold
to build up the thermal protocol of
course this method code should be
different for every protocol then we
will will write the master code for the
intruder the master code for the
intruder could be a syrian air for other
protocol simpler you to that will have
the cinematic ability then we will
remain nothing specify the security
conditions and not marry wrong a method
will find out fun some area than other
or toddlers below this error essentially
in most of the case that others are
caused by bad abstraction that means we
remove the two large details from the
protocol when constructing the
abstracted map meadow on the way in this
very aware of the pieces in and run by
13 by repeating this process recurrent
require fun from generating attack that
will be our mark so the attack is funded
by a former our efforts are really very
strong independent of that kamagra foods
games an independent of that
implementations it's not a structural
problem it's a program of that photo
itself is a very very versatile service
attack are implicit implementation so
here's our review with a failure on
shake the further hundred recall that
the failure handshake will have some PMP
pressure before that when we're around
for 102 is change some random number and
arrival HP so that's the simple and the
porter who sings very good that
available that we are some more
abilities inside it we we use the follow
the Federals to nether the further
handshake the authenticator on the step
you can't we'll have a moment our
association and the each of situation
has a unique mishear p.m. key and there
might be multiple so crucial sessions in
one association for you
the kind of impersonal both supplicant
an authenticator you think I image drop
intercept and reprint messages if you
can compose messages you have surged
message or you can become particularly
pronounces so the environmentally want
to check for the security represents
that security property it must be true
for each state so here the example for
the ultimate cater to send EMS if you
run in mathey code the authenticator is
the ultimate basically multi multi
colored some rules so if the ultimate
evil is in some state in the world to
life insurer here this is if the also k
value do some state it will do the
following actions so let's go to me a
method rule we need to program every 0
other entities is for every state in the
septum and then so that protocol but
members we need to understand the
protocol we reverse me this is the
security properties we want to check or
we want to check via the PTP are
consistent and fresh so unfortunately
only gradually fortunately for for for
for our research project we found some
either attack on this protocol I'm the
solution the solution is a and but is a
tricky program so pay the photo
handshake the selfie cam and under
alternative arrow is change the first
message which was a random number inside
it when they simply can't will derive a
lil random lumber on the drive a new PT
page under send out the new random
number with message protected by the
message integrity check hole then of
them Aceveda will check this message and
under finish this protocol so that a bit
of a package that anniversary has sent
out this message after this commercial
for a handshake finish then upon
receiving this message is African
you have a new random number and then
you have a new PT tape and then the
third attorney will have a king in
concerts and the PT page with like
authenticator so the photo is block
there be one of the protocol the divano
80 pavilion I seems to notice this
program already so they propose a
solution to list which is the use of
amperage GTP to spell to store the
temporary participate in this fellow
handshake and the tempura physically is
copied to a physical only after this
third message is verified let me is well
when the traffic and got this message
either a level refer to that pretty face
but the problem is we will have so much
we're auditory can interfere with the
traffic and pound away so there are lots
of other metal rake I send out the
message Iran such a method on in this
point then you know will change the
temperature to pay off since the fifth
base week its computer in a time
political I mean I don't know what's
wrong with maybe so so the pretty clear
here will be the temporary beautiful
here other words the tempurpedic you
have changed so that so thus a pretender
cannot verify this message so it's it's
very evil values as a program the only
way for the second that you will be able
to finish this protocol if the second
master illustrates of all the incoming
method relies on pretty face you are of
course please cause a denial of service
attack which the adversary has about a
bunch of message want them to fill up
the queue in the Sepik on the side so
for a simple computation we can
calculate this this method the number of
these kind of messages in your a total
11 p network could be very much I mean
if I think if I just
sent out the garbage yeah that's that
that just happy with people make
things not work ah yes I you need to
send out a lot of message which is which
match cover with my gem in the freaking
sale or something like that but for this
vile without you send one message then
the portables block right by simply
sending okay yes okay the PRP could be
derived from a mutual authentication
protocol or it could be pretty
configured to a device or it could be
used to cash your PMP from previous
association yes as we want to derive a
new a thrush secret from this for each
session well fine the way the user is it
is they derive a PT k from this PM k
then use a PT use some part of the PTP
to cut computer hash a collage of the
message so they support so a very simple
solution to this is ultimately prefer
the proposed resolution to raise the
last one or the accepted so the very
simple solution to those either we can
just use a random drop q but 70 chemical
randomly draw a small entry to adapt the
start the states for the incoming method
one evacuees thrilled other combination
should show this this solution it were
so good since the original answer access
access is the lumbermen issues messages
and that vector one is the probability
of
quotable being blocked so with about the
adversary concerned about only 16
messages and plug valve block their
protocol with probability over them
eighty percent even with acusado 10 so
this is not so effective the second
solution is since we have the second
bomber authenticator has already shared
some PMT so they can use that share p.m.
key to authenticate method one then you
don't really use the algorithms and
hardware like I said that to the PTP
that you have from PMP an office they
can say they have said the last two
special value or not appeal then you're
on the ptk and we'll certificate to
verify message this is a good solution
in the PM keep fresh for our session eva
is much you need to pre comparing the or
is cached than the Sun replay attacks
your energy will lose this replay
attacks we need to add a monotonically
increasing global sync encounter this is
simple email for the closest we can use
a local economy often conduct in orphan
killer side where it will need to learn
about the timing synchronization and
whether they are self sufficient space
in that one there are eight octave of
the altar is along for a 60 encounter
but there are some modifications in a
beautiful bath so the left notebook the
first avenger if we can visit the very
tricky one so it's the selfie chemical
reuse allowed Jeremy now okay the kids
are always there wise arrested that you
can never have children possibilities ah
yes okay that's why you can that's what
they are yes so
the subject Anika reuse allows those
canadian security protocol the last
means you will not be fresh every time
here the subject Annika reuse allowance
until wife Erica she completes
successfully so in only four days lost
service for a handshake and you can't
drive correct ptk from buffy through it
you alternate you don't need to remember
methods you remember the ptk and the
incoming last well i think that there is
no requirement for the authenticator so
the solutions from the program is very
simple solution but it costs more
computation in a septic on the side
since the separatists need to compute
the ptk at the first time you cross
method you want and they are set at a
certain time you got got a multi three
you need to recompute it and recompute
the message integrity check so also that
happen like your mother more information
about the PMP since even even a reuse
allowance that means that this as well
see you constant so that this is the
address of the authenticator an address
of the certificate and we're a
laboratory can control this loss so it
must got some information for lives to
mt but if the PMP is strongly laughs
that's that there is no program here so
the program is the performance
performance degradation the milk
computations in a second side so our
side essentially is a combined solution
the selfie cam the reuse a loss is also
spiritual very laws and pdk for the
first message one so if the last unit is
to emerge this entry will use of
critical directa me otherwise we'll
divide people in and use it so the
advantage of this wise is just like the
previous one will eliminate the memory
without service attack completely and
you can ensure performance erm this
scenario really means there might be no
too much attacks in the network and and
with only minor modifications are now
SMS applicant there modifications on the
packet format and a modification on the
portal oh so this one is a
by that tata group I busy very simple
solution actually the wannabe to use
some help I let me define it well
solution is simple but it is not
immediate wait wait before going to
those that we tried many others so on
please please we are looking for a
solution relations over the practical
problem we are going to value a new
protocol so that we may we don't have so
much freedom around a problem for the
failure shaky value plus you impact
since the anniversary under the
legitimate device since that since the
three hundred use symmetry comparable
primitives for sale handshake so very
versatile with less impact the
legitimate device want to communicate
with somebody so you send out this
method you want but there is nobody
there so just that there are three
you're just reply to this message then
then the magical device will generate
this message then strong so till the
time the anniversary don't need to
generate everything so you don't need to
break into the system so in just reply
to the message then the magic other
words the imaginative device will think
it communicated to some peers which is
authenticated but that ultraviolet
nobody there this basis celerity
possible in ad hoc networks since each
participant will clarify the rules of
Authenticator under their septic and it
will cause last image if strong from the
shorty protocols are deputies since
believe the atmospheric have swirl
appears to send packages in collectively
and generous responses always does
violate the mutual education
construction in the protocol so if you
consider it's as you said pack the
solution pervasive we can restrict each
participant to play audio wise walk that
means the ice important to low-level
respond to a message you want a lot of
device relevant will ever generally read
the message one so
stilettos in appropriate for our health
networks so we all have networks each
algebra each participant come play those
roles but you should be under different
PMP this is a very easy mistake to make
since to divide my shares on p.m. key I
very well as Authenticator another epic
and I mean another session in the
protocol standard and other I will run
as an authenticator and later our water
as a septic under so they will use a 7pm
key oh ok let's move left flashing
attack will transfer the legitimate
device send out messages on to somebody
this this map is relative searchable so
the other necessary intersect with this
message and it is one two three you want
to respond to this message you need to
generate a new message to our there's
nothing to it protected by the method
integrity to code and that the other day
doesn't have the cannot general days so
you just reply to this message to the
legitimate device then energy management
device will compute they've Matty to for
the atom every wire it backwards yes yes
the wire then your wife according to a
cumulative that's a state of Connecticut
potentially cannot prevent any phone
calls or inconsistent I always said in
the middle and echo back to do yes razor
is not only standing in the middle that
that there might be there is no active
devices here the atom so reach out to
play first rule they say yeah oh okay
give the poor 12 into the marriage yes
he is over whatever it is yes yes yes
yes yeah yeah
so so here the family Filipino handshake
were useful as the notification to find
a very subtle bugs in the protocol I'm
great this proves the tri-state
verification suitable for verifying
small protocols there are means more
food I mentioned small particles because
the identity verification world foods
they're smooth smooth is pleasuring
problem so there are some companies to
reduce the state space and I will of
talk about them in this talk we found a
message alarm is vulnerable for full of
you know service attack and further one
passenger out one message the atoms away
come throughout the whole protocol you
leave those certain kind of stealth ways
that will schedule service attack so the
solution to receive the second issue
that we use the last and this solution
is adapted by standard County we also
found every flash attack which will
flash attack requires each each energy
either place on your eyes roll back in
your wireless plan scenario i'll flip
for very first roles on the different
p.m. key in our hearts enero 14 years
playing the role that when a friend so
he comes up with yourself again mm-hmm
then it would go back to the others take
observer and get a new p.m. pay for that
hair and when it's like I meditated with
others never again another said it would
again do the same for each case of it
yes yes normal we don't we expected are
you something out of metal sometimes a
pre complete the PMK into the device
yeah so we have we have down there 4a
state verification of all the components
then a lot of sorry we will combine them
together if are already secured
actually we found more programs when we
combine consider the whole intro to
Billy and I as a whole so the first
arrived Larson reporting in problem
austin IE contains less security
parameters of the protocol so their
subsequent an authenticator i will run
we will negotiate about this arson IE as
beginning on the protocol i'm a verified
and at the flavor handshake which is
very late in the protocol so the idea to
confirm this security parameters is good
that the matter they are doing this in
LA so good so and the insurance the
anniversary can send out send out a
deacon with modified arson IE or send
out a provably false with a modified
Alton IE then that this modified only
modified insignificant abuse so the
protocol work will go but until they're
18 message there were the confirmation
will fuel filter commit the confirmation
is a bit by bit compare it comparison on
the in this case the answer only send
out one message or maybe several message
although that the holster tomorrow
gossip web portals world and the whole
site emerald the association so it's
very easy for the attacker to launch the
attack and that legitimate a user might
normally you just continually the
protocol for a server at some point then
we start so then we'll with the
resources in email in love legitimate
devices so the solution to this is first
awake have also carried all the
management frames are less since be
proud too often occur the beacon and
appropriate fast frame since the beating
an improved with one firm is at a very
beginning that will be no secret shared
so a lot of it too we can confirm their
security parameters are so affordable
since
clear economic communities program since
our very beginning to parties them share
everything so the propellers we're going
to approve the order to improve this
removal security only has confirmation
to absolutely possible then away with
the nest resources and data but we are
this needs some modifications on the
standard so there's a solution
palliative we can remap the condition of
that confirmation company that the
condition for confirmation is it will
compile it by beauty and it will fill
another one bit is not much so actually
civ too strict for confirmation we can
evil all the insignificant base only
confirm the authentication suede because
we can emerge in the altercations
relative correct 70s will already do a
correct authentication so weak i use
that we can use the confirm that
security parameters authentication
better protected by a secret so this are
so heavenly verification serrated
modified such a journey that will cost
the protocol to fill immediately then it
will restart and may be found a new
maybe will be found a new at the point
so let's improve the efficiency of the
protocol there is also another security
not a robot attack every way we have
learned that some pecan memory allocator
is changes a security parameters as a
beacon in so suppose the selfie cam and
authenticated based others in the
weather is awesome and very and prerna
clear are certainly means the work
protocol so after after the protocol
then we'll be able to set up an author
and a network so if the anniversary just
search the second message or for to this
one also jamais one such other other are
of them welcome with the indicators
which he says oh
the other as a native in a border then
the second i will choose what prerna
method to connect connect without sin
theta weather across this lately
research iPad web connection but since
well commercially is the insecure so
this is community insecure the probe
which this wine similar to any general
version robot attack it will destroy
well security community service what
we've insecure but i should say it's not
a real one on video of a total value and
I standard since able to build 11 I
suggest everybody to use us away it's a
real bond ability since it also suggests
are trying just earned means an
implementation of Jeff and Jeff amines
transient security network so that means
people might want to migrate from the
web protocol to that most strong for the
greater available I step-by-step then
there might be some period which has
faced web protocols and the author and a
protocols so that I program and there
unless I will you deny and the elements
to do of the network might want to they
measure using the very kind of 104 you
are doing so we just be to transparently
so that the program the solution
previous is we can frustrate hello only
our centenary connections this is
secured by too strict I mean most of the
case I believe us alone will be there
will be the reality in some pure so the
second solution make an adult with those
of the second must manually choose to
devour except that connection when the
organ culture come restricts the web
closure to only in sensitive data
actually we have users in the current
network that means if you are trying to
connect to a network you will have
choice to select is insecure you want to
profit for the program you very well be
use that other we want to make
way too much stronger much stronger
authentication we also need you that you
to such a rapid community insecure why
not it sounds like the perfect
ambassador to my privacy message is in
that rotated responses yes why not have
just a period of time under the
president Connecticut invited to one
third are a moment we are today with our
attorney okay yes let's let's bet on it
yes actually the program evasive first
the adversary can control the message we
have air con ESO the Mafia family way so
you cannot you do know how long you'll
got this message are you Bruno whether
you are several messages from the
elevator reason general message where
the general messages and several social
message you do know anything about that
so you can read have quite a long time
to converse federal reduce the
performance of listening oh yeah it is
possible
yeah yeah it is possible by that okay
let's move on now is also a nun attack
on the microcon Tamara cut them this is
on the cheek IP protocol chi Chi Chi use
a microcosm to compute the message
integrity code and the micro algorithm
it allows to reuse them message device
so if the microcosm will will only
provide 20 bits of security due to the
limitation of the computation power 20
bits of security means in you're able to
play 11 feel at work but I'm sorry can
make a successful surgery every two
minute so obviously was no good so we
need common areas the documentation
proposed the following kalimera first
set we have seized the communication for
60 seconds in two to three days I've
departed then we have a key on the t
authentication of course we clear and
the authentication is not is not a real
solution they have discussion around
aids and they are going to that disabled
days so since weekly and PRP
authentication will leave no time for
the attacker to pure pure tiffany launch
date attack so I really suits
communication for 60 seconds we can
limit the atom authority to search one
successful package every six months so
that's all be good for the applications
and in order to avoid the potential of
service attack when they need to verify
that with packaging a very strict order
the verify this first in in this order
so but in that in the political the
access and also v is completely insecure
so it's searchable the only security is
really in them big here where the skin
very adaptivity the others are
sequence counter enough the milk is
renovated this is a pervasive
problematic since edible an anniversary
kind of intercept a packet with a valid
PSC then you can notify the package
since these two are searchable so you
can modify the package then finally the
package will have varied with two values
at this tsc which as there are also many
others because not valid so if it
resembles the mud modified package price
in one minute lasette amoeba then we are
we are updating this chassis after the
movie is verified as we are proposing
the solutions just it's very tricky just
after the GSC affirmative validated so
he will obviously after the movie
verified it that means in the intact
America message with some effort it's
also easy but it was you got this
message you can resend this message
Iranian again and to process it up so
you obviously prefer this advantage is
that means I forgot this message I
update the GFC then I will our verify
the meeting so the matter you can be
only you surprised I'll see the reason
we want you add the GSA after making
value that is that happens you have
adversely modified chi si tu are
extremely large number I send out a
message without injuring the large
number of Jesse when you are the new
jersey to this number then every other
package with a smirk USA will be decided
by this is not a problem clear actually
phase-change tsc where we also change
the encryption key the chicopee have
some key scheduling algorithm to spread
to mix that you see into the encryption
key so you will issue some confidence in
a g-type EP scheduling algorithm this
will be not a problem now this event
mitigation Bible in it in imitation
since the adversary has been some effort
to god this message you can predict and
we do that if Nick failures cause
sometimes a little big problem follow-up
should always yes yes and the episode is
always know the chance ously not to be
run it that means it's not it's also a
way to bad days since you need at value
DSC I'm the TSA is a mix that with the
encryption key if you didn't break the
encryption scheme you change what just
see there will be not valid you can't so
in this way the anniversary we have some
difficulty to get this package but I
still got it you know can you see it
again and again so it gets tighten
the belt yes yes and yes and now you
think of it oh yeah yes oh no we cannot
attend to make that change no need of it
yes yes it knows all for it yeah in
chess a being that it is run it no just
say advantage don't get so do it the
only thing that's the verified today yes
if so yes in the finger both terrified
yes he will be fair yes now it is
replayed before we verify the make this
place maggot this message is discarded
since the chassis is not valid chief
they should be monotonically increasing
since they have the common area for this
week 15 iya the milk no strong love so
they have counterfeit content Maria
which is if to make formula occurs the
work they'll also
that kind of connection for 60 seconds
right so if I I increase it yes you left
whatever one right and then have a bad
know if you increase the TSA
that's Methodist if you include the
chest see then that encryption key will
not be my encryption key will not be
banished so the matter you will be
decrypt incorrect any that's a hope and
all I want to do yes well that's not
that lesson oh yeah you mean consider
the computation power that you go
through ipod or you need to send a
matter of this message and so this week
senior you want minute i only need to
some to melted here yeah yes penetrate
all I mean you if I check everything
here somebody else to say that active
but of course that package yeah the
program service in these three values
observed values of that then our
audacity of card the method you silent
me right all you want i get through it
yeah part of the mickey bad everything
else is good by making batter so it's
difficult for that adversary to gaza
nice pecky its much difficult much more
difficult for the other three two
thursdays packet yeah maybe we can go to
you yeah there are also many other
attacks fun ball by other people on the
previous altitude relevant network which
is targeting the management frame I
won't talk about the details of them up
in ultra super 11 I we can justify below
the vulnerable messages or simply drop
it our to immediately vulnerability
otherwise over there is only two methods
in left which is the key authentication
and the the Association Association
program okay
it took me less waste evaluate this rep
weight as we are talking about this
Michael yes they want to reuse the net
free device survey Jaffa TTP designed
this back with only 20 base yeah so the
University this will be this will be
replaced replace the bar stronger
algorithm later so the management of
swim attack we're able to regular I can
eliminate most of them but there is two
left which is the the authentication and
dissociation frame since it serves the
only way to remove the attractive to
authenticate frame so another a lot of
programmer with interval um I is a full
recovery program the recovery is very
important for large protocol since
Israel if it will affect their protocol
efficiency and it will even we have a
good to me recover McCallum it'll make
that love service more difficult so able
to very well I a dog's a very simple
scheme we know a finial first even
though we start from the very beginning
so this is obviously very inefficient so
how about recovery is that from a
transparent and this is an intuitive
thing but there is the truth over here
since excellent come in really far from
the lowest point and we should at some
point can capture this user so this
recorder captured yourself attack the
other hand you will be far from the very
beginning if the atom server can drive
this forward to 2010 even though with
the level time so that they will call it
is also if you have service at heart so
it depends on assumptions of the animals
recover
BG on the network six in a row
fortunately that is about half of every
college game for a total value than I
instead of Venus occur before it will
prepare well as reaching for
authentication so before the
authentication finish will just rip out
everything if you haven't often
verification that we really thought from
the very point they see this is a better
solution things will have some
confidence on Las indication here is
authenticated that might not that's not
bad manisha user yes yes if you are
configured to useless yes that's true
yes I remember you asked if I
applicative as well as important then
move to some other session then that
there will be some program and since the
channel spending time with much greater
than the protocol evacuation time that
that's not so severe here so we have the
summarizer you security to the farm so
we have found see securities in the
components like the fellow handshake on
the chicopee microcontroller I presume
we are we will combine the protocol
together we found some for some programs
in the security perimeter negotiation
and we also found some for also from the
official in the recovery so in order to
address all of those vulnerabilities
will prepare that improved version of 80
to verify through the improved version
will use a different failure recovery
and we do authentication them to secure
a situation so we have we have we have
we have found some insecurity we have
proposed a solution and we haven't got
our improve that a total failure a lot
how so
it's easy secure know or if I said okay
I think hard about it that I cannot find
any attacks so do you believe this is
secure I think probably not so the
program is the way need to conduct our
food federal security I all talked about
too much details about the proof and
approve and I will just throw me a
review it the river of security is very
necessary since the house Gretchen
approaches the income convertible and so
a third color useful answered
verification to approve it less less
more the case since email a protocol
past all the verification processes we
can all come to movies secure because it
depends on your coding and the
obstruction of the protocol so also
promote security is useful since during
the processor improving the security we
found bear attacks and it will fix all
mother bear attacks we come back to the
pool so there are some interactions
between the proof and the funding pulse
the difficult difficult program how to
gather the protocol how to define
security how to prove them virtually
means we're already some film a method
to do this like the bar magic under
inventive method in passing and we're
strong and the symbolic and methods or
that from the process catalyst but all
of this method are not suitable for
altitude regular life since a total
value arrive is too large and
complicated control flows we will use a
combination of magic to deal with it
it's oranges from Beecher's paper in
2001 so
sorry I know what's wrong so okay so we
need yourself so here I figure to show
that intuition of the protocol magic if
I don't you talk to somebody then I need
to have its private data and either have
you no its private data it has you know
it's running some protocol with Bob I
mean no it's centered some method you'll
receive a message but these messages
might be sent from all its principles or
attacker so we need to abstract their
protocol fifth a ton of your model we
assume that bloodbath cryptography which
means that with no partial knowledge in
the system and there is no statistical
tests the only way to predict that
progress or function is to have the key
we need a language for profile
description that the previous eras our
marriage Nagaraju are useful in this
part is informer so we use a car called
program for each protocol will also use
semantics to define whole protocol it's
running and we'll need some protocol
magic to study the security properties
and finally we need a personal time to
prove web property pay by example to
show the core programs for the ferry
handshake but this is the core program
in the authenticator side there are some
key the five just to the film program we
consider the protocol is just like the
following program this
clear the conditioner want to check the
precondition X on the right are the
entities in that protocol the
precondition of exhaled p.m. KY GMP an
inveterate p.m. ki will will be X or Y
so the security 14 will want to check it
through the security key agreement which
means you actually only found a light on
it after the photo handshake they will
have some shared ptk and I will also use
the self will also check the security
property of special education but
authentication will divide it if I can
match or the message together in order
yes Phil order then I mean I believe
this session is correct so we proved
will prove all the properties for each
component then other through their them
for the components we need to combine
them to prove the quality of a total am
I your honor to compile them will use
some violence conversation with complete
I want to learn about those conversation
the conversion is very useful when only
for previous but actually we're
following these rules we will build
systems we build several components then
they combine them together so we need to
ensure that they were combined in a
secure way the 22 requirement negative
30 to 90 HR team combination certainly
the additive combination which is just a
single we use environment for every
component to assure the competition in
see there is in order to compel them
silly every the environment of the one
component must be certified satisfied by
any other component we have proven
selling properties this is for for every
component that will prove the special
education and the key agreement then we
pull in a compulsive saving actually we
have welcomed the same tea party indira
that you have service but yeah
further pure memory device surveys we
can deal with it with a material that
computation you'll have a survey data
yes commemorating our surveys that means
if you store something and start again
and again yeah and then we can check it
oh yes yes yes that is it they're all
they're all total level third microwave
oven package yes yes yes that's true so
solar de penser with y'all set the
middle of hunting five of nine yeah move
over so actually the previous tedious
and we do it manually but it can be
automated so it's not a problem now we
can also answering the question how it
in a secure wireless local area network
with altitude Vale mi6 from the author
yes I've a segmentation first security
only means mutual authentication on a
secret key so I me very soon see some
peen secure we have to accomplish OT on
integrity under we arrest me to assume
the perfect black belt cryptography and
I will need to assume that legitimate
entities are only and the this is only
somewhat effective of the protocol will
turn consider source implementations if
there is some software about whether
example flow in this in that
implementation of the protocol when
there might be caused in security
algorithm considers are the other
because of them's in the system like if
you how do you implement a failure
artists are on this process of
application and so on and from that
perspective the protocol is secure so
finally we go to our conclusions we
in these things use the festive
education to verify the components and a
refundable from a tight song on the
protocol and it will prove it's running
secure so now we can build a secure that
is no current Network an interesting a
larger problem it can really feel the
secure all have networks from this we I
will not touch that topic in the top and
you are introduced may be identified
offline I will stand here and I will be
glad to take any questions from you I'm
called after i usually students after
such an thought I said I already better
than ever to youtube and questions in
your wireless way what what what the
proof system you mean yeah yeah the
proof system is based on some axioms
like if I receive the message that
example if I receive the message which
is signed the Python baby so when I
below this method you've come from that
body if we assume their passing is
honest it'll work its curve you know a
lot deployed its private key products we
use this kind of or reasoning so any
other question
now the question thank you